- Is it cold in here? I'm so cold.
We went out on my dad's yacht last night
for like eight hours and
I'm just like still cold.
Humblebrags That Aren't Even Humble
- Yeah, no, I don't even
do anything to my hair.
It just looks this good naturally.
- I actually have to leave early today,
I have to go to the consulate or wherever
to get more pages for
my passport apparently.
- Ugh, it's so hard to go jean shopping
because all of the jeans just
fit me too tight in the frontal area.
- I mean my boyfriend's super hot but like
I gotta sleep, you know,
I can't have sex all the time.
- Yeah, so I take my
sailboat out with my family
on Sunday and we didn't
even see one whale.
We saw a shark, but that was scary.
- Yeah, I got invited to all
these Oscar parties again.
It's just annoying because like
I don't have that many dresses.
- Ugh, I had to turn down
tickets to see Louis CK
because I have backstage
passes to meet Taylor Swift.
- Oh, did I tell you my email got hacked?
Yeah, so like Ryan Phillippe
just got spam from me--
- Man, I'm so mad right now.
The boss just took me out to lunch because
I've been doing such a great
job and he bought me drinks.
Now I'm drunk, I can't even do any work.
- Oh, I'm so hungry.
I have to eat so much.
I just--my metabolism is so fast
and it's just like I
have to keep feeding it.
Like I wish that I could gain
weight, but I just can't.